hello thank you so much for joining this
virtual event I'm Aaron Edwards I'm the
head of services at visit call and today
I'm going to be talking to you about
using 3d cell culture models and high
content confocal imaging to evaluate
efficacy and and to expose toxic
liabilities in the drug development
pipeline so just to give you a little
bit of background about our company and
what we do just so that you have some
context for where I'm coming from with a
lot of what we'll be talking about today
physical has a contract research
organization so we are focused on taking
different types of tissues whether
they're 2d or 3d cell culture models or
whole tissues and transforming those
tissues those 3d models into some sort
of actionable insight through the
services that we offer so these services
can range from traditional confocal
microscopy to in a more traditional
pathology and slide scanning all the way
to more advanced 3d cell culture models
which is what we'll be talking about
today in the basic way that this
pipeline works for us is that we develop
these 3d cell culture models or acquire
these whole tissues take them through
different sorts of processes whether
it's running an actual assay or just
labeling these tissues imaging them
through some some form of imaging
traditionally confocal and then taking
them through a series of image analysis
algorithms in order to pull out these
actionable insights so the question
becomes when we're starting to think
about things in 3d exploring biology and
3d why should we use in vitro tools in
order to expose toxic liabilities or
understand efficacy in the therapeutic
well in comparison to a lot of in vivo
models of course these models are much
less expensive and they can be higher
throughput they minimize some ethical
concerns but what's really interesting
is that a lot of the times they can
actually enable greater translational
relevance so if you think about some of
the difference the differences between
species in terms of things like the
types of transporters or drug receptors
that different species will express
these in vitro models become really
valuable in that we can produce sort of
humanized in
role models and really get the closest
to how a drug would respond in a patient
and then the next question is well why
3d cell culture if you're if you're set
on on taking these in vitro approaches
why move to 3d so cell culture as
opposed to 2d you know traditional 2d
cell culture approaches are very
simplistic they can be very high
throughput and they certainly have their
application but you know cells in the
body don't really exist in a 2d
environment there's cell-cell
interactions ldcm interactions some
transport properties that are really
only able to be recapitulated when you
culture cells in some sort of 3d
environment and just to highlight that
that idea a little bit more we have some
example data here from breast cancer
cell line that was established from a
resected tumor and upon the initial
pathological evaluation of this
respected tumor it was actually found
out that this this breast tumor was
estrogen receptor positive however when
this was taken to a cell line and and
really extrapolated it was found that
that estrogen receptor expression was
lost so you can see here the pictures in
the middle you don't really get much
labeling for estrogen receptor when we
take these cells into 3d cell culture we
actually see that that estrogen receptor
expression is once again restored as it
was in the native tissue that that
initial tumor resection and what's
thought to be behind this is is that
that cell sell and sell GCM interaction
that regulates expression of a number of
proteins in this case estrogen receptor
but why would that be functionally
important well especially when you're
screening drugs perhaps those that are
targeting the estrogen receptor this can
be really important because you want to
make sure that your system recapitulates
the in vivo case as much as possible so
we did a simple comparison of a number
of antineoplastic agents here and and
I'd like to draw your attention in
particular to full the strand which is
boxed in a dotted black box here what we
saw is that the draw the the
the breast cancer cells this wood cell
line was much more sensitive to
treatment with fullest wrath when it was
cultured in 3d versus cultured in 2d
this is a bit counterintuitive because
you would think if cells are cultured in
2d they're much more exposed to a drug
so you'd think that they'd be more
sensitive but of course as those cells
are not expressing the target of
interest they're not going to respond in
the way that we'd expect so just sort of
an interesting case here underscoring
the the importance of using 3d cell
culture models in in a way that allows
us to recapitulate the in vivo micro
environment and actually see the the
sorts of responses that you'd expect
based on those differences that you can
see between 2d and 3d environments but
it's important to note that 3d cell
culture is not really a
one-size-fits-all solution so as I
touched on 2d cell culture models can
still be very useful tools they're much
higher throughput so they allow us to
run many more asses than can be
accomplished with 3d cell culture models
a lot of the time consuming portions of
running these 3d cell culture model
based assays comes from actually
evaluating the entire tissue so rather
than taking one optical plane if you're
using imaging to analyze your ear
tissues instead you have to take a
series maybe 10 15 these steps in order
to really fully characterize those
tissues so you get much greater
relevancy you sort of you know is that
the cost of throughput and of course
these models can be a bit more expensive
but if you compare them to things like
animal models or even clinical testing
you know we're still moving towards that
lower cost and higher throughput range
so they sort of say somewhere between
judy cell culture models and those
higher order in vivo models and and
really everything has its application
somewhere along the pipeline so the idea
here is not to completely replace animal
models but to sort of stream things down
so we can get there much more quickly
and effectively I also wanted to touch
on on a little bit of nomenclature here
so you'll hear folks use different
different terminology for 3d cell
culture models
we sort of used as catch-all term three
cell culture models to explain any sort
of three-dimensional aggregate of cells
steroids in particularly are generally
reserved for stem cell contexts for
example there's that spheroid forming
assay and evaluating cancer cell
stemness but but a lot of the times
you'll see this term steroid use more
broadly for any sort of sphere shaped
amalgamation of a couple of different
cells maybe one or multiple cell
subtypes then you'll hear the term micro
tissue used a lot of the time this is
sort of designed to mimic more so the
functionality of in vivo tissues so it
couldn't refer to either cell culture
models so like a steroid or sometimes
even excise tissues so some folks will
take tumor biopsies and cut them up into
much smaller pieces and use those as
quote-unquote micro tissues in order to
screen their therapeutics and the last
category that shows that you'll hear
used a lot is organoids these are much
more organized about the matrix of cells
and it's usually this term is applying
to cells that have been derived from
some sort of stem lineage so it's really
a long term guided differentiation
process that gives you this larger
structure so here a lot about I PFC
derived neural organoids is a very very
common usage of that term but overall
when you're considering working with 3d
cell culture models from a perspective
of building these 3d cell culture models
there's a couple considerations that are
worth thinking about so first of all as
the source material you can use cell
lines primary cells or even stem cells
and each kind of has its pluses and
minuses so cell lines are very easy to
work with they're pretty inexpensive
reproducible but of course there are
some changes that occurred on the
immortalization process that make some
some of their applications a little less
well-suited so sometimes the
the preferences use primary cells
they're much more challenging
there's lots a lot of variability
they're more expensive and you can
really only use them once you can't
continually propagate these guys in
culture in order to run multiple
experiments on the same lot
and then there's stem cells these are
sort of much more challenging and take
much longer to develop just due to the
oftentimes long differentiation
protocols that are required so this
usually puts them in a more low
throughput category and then once you've
chosen your source material and you want
to generate the 3d cell culture models
there's a couple of other considerations
the the means of generating 3gg models
have kind of evolved over the years one
of the earliest approaches was the
hanging drop approach where an cells are
seated in a drop that hangs from a plate
insert so sort of an inverted case but
there's a number of other approaches
that have been improved upon making that
the technology much more accessible for
example this magnetic printing where in
magnetic nanos are used to sort of
encourage aggregation you can use matrix
based approaches or my personal favorite
is the ultra low attachment plates so
these are you bottom plates that have a
coating on them that that prevent
adhesion of the cells to the bottom of
the plate thus the cells are much more
likely to aggregate they're very easy to
use push again lends to the sort of more
high-throughput nature of this approach
there's always new plates and approaches
to generating 3d cell culture models
that are in development so a lot of
technology here so a lot of different
approaches and sometimes one approach is
more favorable than another for getting
different cell subtypes to aggregate so
one of the biggest challenges especially
when you use primary cells is actually
getting cells to a great sometimes you
get in the picture on the far left here
just little micro aggregates of only a
few cells sometimes they're very
irregularly shaped as you can see on the
far right but what we're typically
aiming here
for here is a nice spheroidal
aggregation as you'll see in the center
now when you're looking to evaluate
these 3d cell culture models you know
you run your guesses maybe you're
screening compounds whether it's for
efficacy or toxicity there's a couple of
different ways that you can interrogate
them right you can use some standard
biochemical analyses and different types
of assays pretty low cost most times the
throughput can be high depending on the
type of assay that you're looking to run
but a lot of the time you're not getting
any spatial or cellular information
similarly you can dissolve the steroid
and use immuno labeling based approaches
or other dyes and use flow cytometry to
evaluate your cells so you get some
cellular information here but again
you're losing this spatial organization
of that larger 3d structure so the next
step up in complexity and thus a little
bit more expensive as well is to use
wide field imaging however this will
only allow you to really characterize
the cells at the periphery of your 3d
cell culture models just because that
your objects are limited in terms of
being able to actually get good new
resolution you're allowing so much out
of plain light in that you're not going
to be allowed to actually see each
individual region of your 3d cell
culture model as you image through it so
in order to get a little bit more
perspective on the different regions of
3d cell culture models a lot of folks
will use histopathology so you can think
of this from larger tissue scale we are
suctioning larger tissues into a couple
of micron slices a similar approach can
be taken using steroids but you can
imagine if a spheroid is only 100 200
300 microns this histopathology approach
becomes very tedious and very low
throughput it's very difficult to get a
steroid evenly bisected using
histopathology and then to get repeat
sections in order to get some 3d context
there so ultimately one of the really
nice approaches is to use can focal
microscopy you're able to image deep
into the tissue
and really only be visualizing a few
cell layers at a time so the cost does
go up the cost per well in order to
conduct this sort of analyses just
because the time that's required and
thus that the throughput is a bit lower
but you get a lot more information out
of it here one of the challenges though
about using good focal microscopy is
that you are sort of limited in depth so
you can see from the image on the right
the top two rows here we have a steroid
and you're going if you're going from
left to right and continuing on the
bottom row here you can see that as you
image deeper and deeper into the
spheroid you sort of start to lose the
cells at the centre of this here right
and the reason for this is that all of
the the individual cells and their
components are sort of acting at like
lenses and diffracting the light as it
passes through each cell layer
especially when you get to the center of
the zero and you really you're losing a
lot of light and thus you're not able to
see those cells that are at the center
so we've developed a number of tissue
clearing reagents these are commercially
available through the remote Fisher
under the name Saito Vista and you can
see that if you now take that same see
writings cleared it and you look at that
z stack going deeper and deeper in Z now
you can actually see all of the cells
throughout the entire depth of the 3d
cell culture model and this of course
allows us to see more total cells so you
can see her from this graph as we're
going through every Z slice we're
getting many more cells that are
actually able to be imaged and again the
reason for this is the ability of the
light to actually pass through the
entire cell so the clearing reagents are
a refractive index matching solution
such that that incident light no longer
gets scattered instead it's able to pass
directly through these 3d cell culture
models so by allowing for that more
complete characterization you can think
of things like you know if there's some
sort of heterogeneous distribution of
how cells are responding to a
therapeutic now you're able to much more
effectively characterize that rather
than
characterizing the cells on the exterior
surface so I wanted to dive into an
example here of an important application
of 3d cell culture models this is liver
toxicity and disease so we've developed
at visit call a number of 3d cell
culture models in order to study both
liver toxicity and disney's these range
from either mono cultures of just
hepatocyte or have our G cells to more
complex co-cultures with other
supporting cell types so in the model
that I'll talk most about today we've
used HEPA RG cells which are in
immortalized hepatocyte line since the
hepatocyte progenitor and these have
been Co cultured with a mix of non
parenchymal cells derived from human
liver
so those non parenchymal cells sort of
support the liver function in a number
of ways so I'll go through briefly here
each of the cell types that's sort of
featured in this model of course we have
the hepatocyte like cells these produce
bile they sort of function to metabolize
a lot of drugs they store glycogen and
lipids and then comprise about 70 to 80
percent of the liver liver sinusoidal
endothelial cells here are labeled with
seeming 31 they form this sort of highly
fenestrated sinusoid network that runs
through the liver and really facilitates
that blood filtration capacity of the
liver then we have kupffer cells these
are sort of macrophage like cells they
patrol those liver sinusoids and the
incite an inflammatory response when
appropriate
there are stellate cells when these guys
become activated in a lot of disease
contexts they actually started producing
a lot of extracellular matrix which can
lead to fibrosis especially in the
context of some diseases we'll talk
about in a few minutes here and then
there's some other supporting cell
subtypes here I'm highlighting calandria
sites these form sort of these bile duct
structures that help transport file
through
deliver and out of the liver and there's
a number of other cells that we haven't
really talked you about here that are
derived from this non Frank molt
population but altogether these liver 3d
cell culture models an able to enable us
to ask a number of different questions
so one of the first things that we've
looked at using these models is
drug-induced liver injury the ability to
evaluate toxicity in in resulting from
different types of therapeutics so in
this case we dosed those heavier gene on
parenchymal co-culture models with
increasing doses of acetaminophen in
order to demonstrate this principle of
using imaging to evaluate toxicity in
these 3d cell culture models so the 3d
cell culture models have been labeled
with both a viability indicator here
shown in green and a mitochondrial
health indicator so the viability
indicator works by exclusion so a
compromised membrane allows the
viability indicator in and it gets fixed
in place so the more green you see the
more dead cells and you can see that as
we increase the dose of acetaminophen
will get more dead cells but what's
really nice about imaging is you can
start to layer some of these different
assays on top of one another to start
start to understand a mechanism behind
toxicity or therapeutic efficacy so in
this case you used a mitochondrial
membrane potential indicator because
it's supposed that if a drug is
cholestatic in its mechanism of
drug-induced liver injury you actually
get a cumulation of bile acid that can
cause damage to the mitochondria so here
we do see there is some of that effect
here with the dosing with acetaminophen
such that we see a loss of mitochondrial
membrane potential with increasing dose
of acetaminophen and to highlight
another aspect of these three cell
culture models the inclusion of immune
cell subtypes and not just liver 3d cell
culture models but a number of 3ds
our models has become increasingly
recognized as important to effectively
screening different types of
therapeutics for either toxicity or or
efficacy so in this case we've dosed
with trove ofloxacin with and without
stimulation with lipopolysaccharide and
we see that we get a pretty dramatic
shift in the dose response curve when we
either stimulate or don't stimulate
presumably due to the immune component
that's present within these 3d cell
culture models in addition to these
imaging based approaches we can also
layer on top a number of other non
imaging based approaches a lot of the
time using the same spheroid well so you
can multiplex for five different colors
within a single spheroid but then you
can also take self ultra supernatants
and analyze those for things like bile
acid secretion LDH release we can look
at reactive metabolites urea production
the list goes on so it's a really nice
way to evaluate a number of different
endpoints especially when you might have
this increased relevancy afforded by 3d
cell culture models and the last thing I
wanted to talk about with these 3d cell
culture models particularly in the liver
context is liver disease so not just
screening toxicity but more complex
processes that maybe can't quite be
screened in 2d so non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease is growing in prevalence
in the United States and across the
world really and it sort of starts with
this this abnormal lipid accumulation
and as those lipid droplets continue to
accumulate you get increased
inflammation that inflammation
eventually activates the scaly cells
that we talked about a bit earlier and
leads to deposition of a lot of
extracellular matrix and this is termed
fibrosis and this ultimately leads to
sort of an advanced cell damaged state
and a lot of scarring but impairs liver
functionality so there's currently no
approved therapeutics for to address
that end-stage fibrotic state so a lot
of folks are looking
to evaluate these compounds but the
current 2d assays don't really do such a
good job of evaluating compounds in this
arena we started out with span ptosis
that accumulation of lipid in in the
liver here we used a much more
simplistic 3d cell culture model and I
just wanted to call attention to that so
we used have g2 cells which is an
immortalized liver carcinoma cell line
and the reason being is they can be much
a sort of more high-throughput just
because you can continue to propagate
these cells in culture without the need
to continually you know resaw primary
material and worry about the lots a lot
variation there so this sort of brings
down the cost of this assay at the
expense of of the sort of later stage
evaluation of more advanced stages of
the disease but it allows us to get a
good approximation at least if you're
looking to do some side-by-side
comparisons so it's always good to think
about what's the most important endpoint
in this phase of the assay and you can
always continue to build on that and
really optimize what you're looking for
in terms of cost throughput and in vivo
relevancy so here we use these have to
choose your eyes we go some with
increasing concentrations of oleic acid
and you see that the amount of lipid per
cell does in fact exhibit this dose
response that we'd expect to see again
we can multiplex this with some
different endpoints not just these
imaging based endpoints we can look at
things like tnf-alpha secretion so you
can start to get a sense of that next
step that inflammatory step but
ultimately if you're looking to evaluate
disease in this case fibrosis those
jelly cells that I mentioned earlier are
really the key to allowing these the the
recapitulation of that disease state
there are the guys that are gonna get
activated and deposit ECM so we really
have to be a part of the model in order
to recapitulate that disease most
effectively so here we took the same
that heavy our gene on
Malco culture based approach treated
with tgf-beta in order to stimulate
fibrosis and looked at a number of
different imaging based readouts so we
looked at activation of stellate cells
here shown in green these two green
markers pdgfr beta and alpha SMA and we
see that we get a great increase in the
amount of stelae cell activation when we
stimulate with tgf-beta likewise those
stellate cells are they start to deposit
collagen here labeled either collagen
one or pan collagen to label multiple
college and subtypes at once and we see
that we do get increased deposition of
collagen as well you have been a number
of proposed approaches to ameliorate
this fibrotic state one of which is to
treat with some sort of al v inhibitor
so simple therapeutic if you will that
we've used here isn't how v inhibitor
and we see that it does ameliorate
fibrosis to a pretty significant extent
similarly we can multiplex these with
other non imaging base tosses to look at
things like cytokine production alt and
ast you know commonly used metrics to
evaluate liver functionality and we
again see that we stimulate with
tgf-beta you get some sort of fold
increase in these different cytokine
readouts but when you treat with an OP v
inhibitor we get that amelioration of
the disease state so that's just one
example of using 3d cell culture assays
in order to sort of study a disease more
effectively but there's a number of
other examples out there for this 3d
advantage if you're looking at
evaluating drug delivery approaches how
well a therapeutic you can penetrate a
solid tissue of course you need some
sort of solid tissue in order to
evaluate you can't just treat a mono
layer of cells so here I have a couple
images on the top left of a steroid
bottle that we've used to evaluate drug
delivery in a 3d cell culture model then
on the right here you see evaluating
selim filtration so very similar to
evaluating drug delivery as folks move
more and more towards these cellular
based approaches to treating disease or
evaluating the immune component of
different diseases understanding cell
infiltration in particularly immune cell
infiltration becomes an important
question so by using 3d cell culture
models we're actually able to do that
again if you just have cells on a 2d
mono layer you can't really look at what
they're infiltrating and some of these
studies can be conducted using excised
tissues it just becomes a lot more low
throughput so having this ability to
recapitulate that that state whether
it's a disease State or the treatment
state using a 3d cell culture model is a
really powerful tool and then on the
bottom left here I've given sort of a
slightly different take on the 3d
approach evaluating drug permeability in
a blood-brain barrier model it's sort of
a less 3d 3d cell culture model but you
do still have some sort of 3d context of
looking at the transport of some sort of
material in a 3d context rather than an
in the cellular based model rather than
in a traditional approach there's many
many other applications of this
advantage of 3d cell culture models and
acids and I hope you take the
opportunity to explore them a bit be
happy to take any questions and I look
forward to following up with each one of
you on any questions that you may have